So my Danny Glover story is
Morgan Freeman was making a show recently
talking about his films.
And so Danny was like going
(speaks gibberish)
good to see you good to see you
I met his grandson at an event he's like
(speaks gibberish)
yo your brothers are funny
your brothers are funny.
So Morgan Freeman told
a story on this show
that he was doing that Danny Glover
had seen Shawshank Redemption
and had come to him
to tell him how much he
enjoyed Shawshank Redemption.
And he walks up to Morgan and he goes
(speaks gibberish)
I gotta tell you man I
saw that movie last week.
You were so good in the
shrimpshamp reduction.
I'm sorry the shrimpshamp?
You're telling me I'm the
the shrimpshamp reduction?
You were so good in it
the shrimpshamp reduction.
The shrimpshamp reduction?
The shrimpshamp reduction.
I was not aware that I
did two movies last year.
Oh my god that's the
(speaks gibberish)
and then here's Jordan
Peele's and I'll let you
do your Danny, I know I'm tripling up.
Jordan Peele's Danny Glover
that he did a two man show about
ten years ago.
Wait wait wait wait wait
no riggs riggs riggs riggs.
There's a bomb on the deck.
(speaks gibberish)
it's the best!
The fact that he can get it that--
you got a tattoo? A tattoo like popeye?
You got a tattoo like popeye?
He says popeye 74 times in three seconds.
To the little boy,
because he's trying to see
if someone has a tattoo
like Martin Riggs' tattoo.
(speaks gibberish)
tattoo like popeye like
popeye popeye like popeye?